yeah it should be out now so I really
want to thank the organizers for the
invitation it's really nice to drive up
here with our traffic this morning so
I'm just down the South Bay I'm a junior
faculty at in your neurosurgery
department so my lab is really
interested interesting study of my
movement control and watch continue the
the topic on basal ganglia circuits so
as you can see you know for this
baseball player in order to hit a
perfect homerun
you have to have a instantaneous
integration of motor and sensory
information right you have to have your
target you have to constantly judge the
speed and direction of your balls so
your brains doing all kinds of
computation so my lab obviously kind of
studies baseball players directly we use
mice as a model organism for example can
train the mice to perform a food
reaching task and study them fine motion
but today I'm not going to talk about
behavior I'm gonna focus it on the
neurons darting is important for
encoding these sequence of motions so
for example
josh has nicely alluded to the circus
that is responsible for fine movement
control I'm not gonna go detail into the
circuit architect I just want to mention
that the basal ganglia which is a group
of interconnected nuclei it's very
important for integrating these
converging synaptic inputs and not only
important for movement control but also
for a variety of other functions here
and the whole circuit is heavily
modulated by dopamine signals like what
josh mentioned and this function of the
dog-bone dopamine signal can lead to
movement disorders and also various form
of addiction behaviors so we really want
to understand the underlying cellular in
the neural circuit mechanism English
neural circuits so how do we do this
right many of us actually think about
the brain like a computer circuits so in
order to understand the brain we need to
understand the circuit the basic
fundamental question is trying to
understand how these neurons integrate
the inputs so to do this we imagine four
the central neurons singing surgeons a
brain region as a computational elements
so as we give inputs and then we can
spin around output so in my talk I'm
going to focus on the spinal projection
neurons in the striatum which the
principal projection neurons in the in
the stratum
so how do we study this there are many
many ways right so for example here I
show example the work done by a hallway
down scoop so you can do large-scale
circuit racing for example in this case
use a viral virus based tracing look how
to find projections from various
possible cortex into different parts of
the striatum right so this way you can
build a large scale whole animal a scale
of projection levels this is the
anatomical data obviously this is not
enough to understand function the other
way is to read out an output similar to
what Josh does for example recording the
activity of the neurons in this case
actual example done by my colleague Mark
Spencer using the mini scope and then
simultaneously record hundreds of
neurons to the activity in Bri behaving
animal so my lab actually does neither
of this we really try to understand the
cellular and subcellular function that
is bridging these findings so come back
to the spiny projection or us we in
order to understand the computation we
really need to know the inputs and then
know the outputs right so what kind of
inputs do these neurons receive they
receive a variety of excitatory inputs
and modulatory inputs for example motor
cortex as you can imagine we need a
motor commands generated in the motor
cortex at the same time we need a
sensory feedback to adjust our motion
these are primarily coming from this as
well somatosensory cortex and also we
also need to respond to salience in the
stimulation that attentional shift
signals these are mediated by ceramic
inputs primarily powerful C clear and
settled medium nuclei and all of these
aspects are heavily modulated by
dopamine inputs like what josh mentioned
so how do we understand this computation
and how these inputs are computing the
single neuron level generator the action
potential output this is what I'm going
to focus on today so I'm going to try to
answer three fundamental questions
actually many of us has been trying to
tackle for many many years
first is many many of the these
conversions etc synapses coming from for
example m1 s one thalamus they are all
good interject do they actually form
some kind of organizes Knapton inputs
down to the dendrites of meanest by
neurons and if they do how these
convergence nothing but are computed on
these dendrites and translating to
spiking outputs and lastly if I have
time I'll mention you know these spiking
how are they are fine-tuned by the
inhibitory Network within the stratum
and of course these inhibitor inputs are
also driven by these excited excitations
so how do we do this actually I'm
experimentalist in our lipo track
primarily use experiments to measure the
outputs and control the inputs and then
recently we started exploring using
computational message to guide our
experiments so how do I do experiments
we use combining electrophysiology and
two photon imaging oh can perform Hotel
patch clamp recording seeing the
targeted neurons and they're recorded
synaptic activities or spiking
activities in response to either current
injections or synaptic simulations at
the same time we can load that cell with
dye to guide us the to study the
morphology or targeted stimulation and
simultaneously we can look at calcium
signal in these neurons in very fine
structures such as dendrites or spines
so though in order to understand the
commutation first we really need to
precise control control the inputs using
genetic methods so thanks to invention
of you after genetics we can express
your adoption in very specific areas in
the more
cortex or thalamus and then stimulated
these inputs and look at the output
right for example we use mx1 Cree in
which Creek ominously expressed in all
cortical neurons either by crossing with
the AI 32 miles where charrid oxen can
be expressed in the Cree depend manner
or working inject a V mediate a Cree
dependent expression which are adopted
in this way we can control the
pteridophyta
either in all cortical areas throughout
the cortex or in the define the region
for example in this case is asked 1 and
this is how we express channelrhodopsin
motor cortex we can use the different
cui liability - for example in this case
to express your apps in thalamus and
that these are targeted area what if you
want to do sparse labeling for example
can use Taiwan channel Robson why why
appeal I in this case random group of a
layer 5 parameter neurons in the cortex
express channelrhodopsin so in so
provide us additional control we can
stimulate a sub selective group of
minora in the cortex or a target group
of neuron in the whole entire region so
all these manipulations can nicely
express Harrison and not only in the
cell body but also in the axonal
terminals so which allow us to record
and stimulate in the brain slice for
example in this case we would record a
postsynaptic neuron Lotus always the
morphology dye and Counting dye and
locally we can activate these child
often expressing axons and that we can
observe a calcium transient in the
target area in this case we can defy
functional connection between the child
often expressing axons and the
postsynaptic spines so this is how the
real expansion works you can pay
attention to the blue dot here this is
where the cherubs and stimulation is
turned out and then you can see calcium
transients very defined in this spot so
we can who can do this way and
repeatedly again again through a
dendritic
barbar and we do this multiple times
because you know synaptic transmission
is probabilistic we want to capture the
most functional connections so this is
how data looks like if we go through the
dendritic tree in this case to major
dendrite singing this one spiny
projection neurons in this case the
chair adopts a expressing the s1
cortical straight of projection axons
all these red spines are Market Market
alum dendrites indicate the function of
synapses coming from the s-1 cortical
Strider projections okay so if you look
at these distribution distribution you
know we did this I mean many many spines
and many many neurons a few obvious
conclusion can immediately made first is
the inputs coming from the s1 do not
have are not segregated into different
dendrites any danger I will look we
always have inputs along the dendritic
tree in the region where the neurons
receive as one inputs and the other
thing to put a conclusion we made is
that we can make is that the s-1 inputs
do not have distal or proximal
preparations for example your famous a1
pyramidal neurons in the hippocampus
receive different inputs in the distal
tops versus in the middle or versus
basil dendrites this is not a case for
straight of projection neurons so what
are the organization right so the first
thing you can notice that we do see some
kind of clustered inputs that are
congregating the sub-region of the in
the dendrites is this true we performed
on different levels of cluster analysis
one of example is the nearest neighbor
test in the middle is more random
distributed dots
on the left is more dispersion on rice
is more clustered by calculating the
distance the distance with its neighbors
we can get a reliable measure of T
scores and P values where the on the
right is indicating is perfectly
disparate inputs on the left is
perfectly clustered so our data gives
very nice indication of clustered inputs
when the child options are expressed in
either somatostatin cortex or the motor
cortex and this is not true when we
randomly express channelrhodopsin
throughout the cortical regions in this
case we're used to tie one chart up
there as I mentioned before the inputs
are randomly distributed and we have a
p-value where greater than 0.05 and this
is also not the case for dynamic inputs
in this case we express Heron opsin
using the agouti to cream eyes and you
can see also the inputs are perfectly
randomly distributed through the
dendritic tree so what does tell us this
tells us actually cortical inputs
specifically from s1 or m1 are a
clustered along with angelica tree but
how clustered is the cluster in order to
end this in order to estimate how big
the cluster is we use the replicate
function to to to do that masses so what
is this analysis you can imagine yes we
use a modified the 1d version of it it's
just 2d version is easier to explain
that's why I used for the background
yeah so again for the replicape a
function we also use a modified 1d
version of it so what is the replicape
function so you can imagine you were
walking into a botanic garden right all
the butcher ropes rose bushes are
together all the comforts are together
in a Japanese garden so this is the way
to estimate how clusters of these same
pants in the same region right so by
measuring the distance and between other
objects within the radius for example in
this case we can generate the random
distribution if the true distribution is
above this random distribution is
suggested significant cluster for
example the rose bushes in the Botanic
Garden or
the below this line is Sigma dispersed
for example the trees along the main
street I
in most of towns right so we use one the
this modified 1d version of analysis I
look at the cortical inputs in this case
you can sort of see already right here
what it's it's it's more than just
density I think you know takes more than
a few minutes to explain we can we can
talk afterwards yeah different exons for
your cluster yes yes we do yes
so these clusters from cortex yes indeed
is a significant beyond the random
distribution and if you perform the same
analysis in this case using side watch
are optimized you can see that the true
distribution forcing the 95% confidence
interval of the random distribution so
we can do this in many many dendrites in
many many cells and estimate how big is
the cluster is so by estimating the
region that is beyond the random
distribution which gives a measure about
cluster length about 30 microns within
this 30 micron cluster we get about 10
spines that are cluster from specific
region of inputs why this is the
important because we think it's actually
it's important way to encode the
different samples in doing specific
behavior for example if the assemble of
activity and their inputs are converged
into the set onto the same dendrite can
we enhance the computation of this
Australia projection neurons but if you
sparse a label cortical neurons
throughout or court or thalamus neuron
and then they randomly distribute they
they can immediate different level of
competition so this is that summation
right how do we measure the competition
so let's move on to the second part so
look at the distribution right the first
thing we want to do is
can we actually go activate these
synaptic inputs at the same time so the
way we're to do to do it is to use two
photon caging of Kaija crewmate this is
a compound of Katie boom a the red
circle is a active glutamate compound
upon absorbing photons the right
wavelength this compound can be cleaved
and release groom a because two photons
citation volume extremely small we can
precisely control where we activate
these synaptic inputs for example here I
show this targeted spy if we simply move
the uncaging spout 1 micron away we can
lose the synaptic response so this is a
very precise way to target the
individual spines along the dendritic
Arbor so we can do this for example on
this specific stretch of dendrite we can
target target these spines one by one
and in the random way if the dendrites
is the computing the linear fashion we
can calculate the original sum if the
dendrites are calculating these inputs
in a nonlinear way we can compare the
measure response with the erisa
mathematics um which is generated this
curve you are probably already can gas
the dendrites actually are computing
this is accepted excitatory inputs in
the superlinear way in this specific
case the nine spine is already a
significant the standard that are unit
to lie so this is not surprising this
phenomenon has been shown in many types
of other neurons Co activation of
clusters adapting inputs can enhance the
dendritic integration this is obviously
in addition to a simple that you do
computation right so if you compute the
inputs in the linear way you can put a
threshold and generate action potential
yes or no fashion and then the nonlinear
way up to certain threshold the the
activation of cluster inputs can
generates its big plateau potential in
the dendrites and actually people from
barley smelts group more than attackers
ago has nicely shown in the in theory
the dendritic UNAM linear integration
painting has computation capacity in a
very engli single neuron levels so how
does this mean for the stratum a
projection neurons what we need to look
at the action potential outputs right
but we can only stimulate a few
dendrites dendritic spikes obviously
obviously this is not sufficient so we
really want to test the idea that if for
the ninjetta good non-linearity happens
and then we can activate other synaptic
inputs at the same time does this
facilitates action potential generation
to do this you know we collaborate with
our generic hugger hoop at the
Karolinska Institute and the G do a chi
do her students so students generate the
detailed model for spiny projection
neurons using the realistic morphology
of Australia of spanning projection
neurons and this model has been a
recently published and being available
on the model dB so in this neuron we can
insert all the known
ion channels since that synaptic
conductances using the normal
distribution published in the previous
papers so this this model can very
faithfully recapitulate the excitability
of minora for example in response to
current action or spontaneous synaptic
inputs or inhibitory and excitatory and
inhibitory inputs and how about the
nonlinear events as I mentioned if we do
two photons Wilma engages in the stretch
of dendrite
we can evoke this nice dendritic events
english' so dendrite and this is also
true if we do local electrical
stimulation but what about a
computational model yes this model can
very nicely
model this terrific non-linearity as
well this is the example a movie how the
simulation was generated you can see
that this is the realistic morphology of
the neurons and you can see
these hotspots this is where the a
cluster of excitatory inputs are
activated within the short time window
you can see locally you can generate the
large depolarization and maintains the
plateau potential even measure soma so
now we can do a very fine experiments
right
so using this model you can generate
this non-linearity in the distal
dendrite and then compare it to when the
proximal dendrites are activated where
only you get a regular
epsp at the background we can give
high-frequency inputs to mimic ongoing
cortical activity and of course with
synaptic background as I mentioned these
neurons are extremely hyper per eyes and
actually even at 10 Hertz with 10 320
snapping inputs these cortical inputs
only can generate a few minerals of the
inputs but what happens now when you
have the Angelika are a plateau
potential you can see these inputs are
mimicking the 10 Hertz inputs and this
is dendritic synaptic inputs and then
when they collide you can generate a
full-blown action potential and then to
do a statistical measure can run this
kind of simulation many many times
for example 1000 times and get a
statistical measure so this is what
happens with without dendritic Alanya
rarity you have very low percentage of
generating a football action potential
when you do have dendritic patio
potential you have way higher action
potential generation in these neurons
and you can see the integration window
is broadened yes so you just told us
that and say that's one
branch only one segment so so in this
case we just activate snapping Memphis
within this short stretch by controlled
fashion if you hold your question for a
couple more minutes hopefully I can
answer you so this can broaden the
integration window and and also we can
control the cortical inputs in the
proximal intermediate nor destroy inputs
without the dendritic Plateau potential
you can imagine that the the proximal
inputs would have higher impact on
spiking because they have fewer
dendritic are filtering facts but in the
press in the presence of dendritic
Plateau potential this spatial window is
broadened which means that now the
neuron really doesn't care where the
inputs are coming from there are equal
for generating these action potentials
so to summarize this part how do the
converging inputs are converted into
spiking output we think that cluster
snapping was support the generation of
dendritic patio potential and this can
greatly broaden the spatial and temporal
window for integration in for
integrating incoming inputs and the
facilitate the spiking generation and
this is particularly important for
spanning projection neurons because they
are dominated by potassium channels on
the dendrites and they do not express
for example I H they have very high
performance the membrane potential
previously Theory work has estimated
that because quad coil puts make a very
few connections with these neurons we
need to activate hundreds of neurons at
very high frequency to generate action
potential but using this non-linearity
now we only requires tens of neurons for
generating a spiking activity so lastly
what about inhibition
quickly previous work by many many
groups for example nicely summarized by
crisis group of here showing different
inhibitory inputs in the stratum are
engaging in the v4
Bishan and they vary in tangent location
and also strength and the kinetics of
visa are inhibitory inputs again in the
model we can nicely insert these
conductances and play with timing in
this case we can put a PP internal
immediately for education primarily
targeting the soma with large
conductances and a fast kinetics and we
can also model the dangers targeting
ambition for example mediated by either
a collateral user collateral sorry
medium spiny neurons or I don't know
what happened or a somatostatin positive
into neurons or we can model the target
dendritic targeting slow kinetics IPS
sees mediated by a neuroglia form of
inter neuron which is MPI positive so as
it shown before when you couple the
class the inputs and the non cluster
inputs you can generate steady spiking
output now you can activate the in
general and the look has different
inhibitor inputs the impact of different
hitting inputs are on these spiking
activity first we activate our GABA
inputs needed by fast backing two
neurons in the previous literature has
been suggest that because they have
largest conductance it has heavies in
innovation on these neurons they should
have the biggest impact of spiking
generation but however because there are
somatic they targeted which is way away
from the general nonlinear events the
impact actually pretty small if we do
the same simulation now we activate
these dendritic locally locally targeted
inhibitory inputs you can see that it
has a way more dramatically factor on
spiking generation and another
interesting phenomenon is that you can
see this very nice window where only the
input inhibiting is coming in about 40
to 50 milliseconds delayed from the
cluster inputs actually has the biggest
impact and if you slow down this
connected even more the mpy meet
internal immediate the slow inhibition
has an even stronger impact so this give
us a very nice prediction as
experimentalist we really want to test
what's true actually the timing of the
dendritic you localize this inhibition
actually matters to do this we went back
to the experiment I'm just showing you
one of the configurations we tested for
example we can record this by any
projection neurons Express chair adopts
a in the neighboring means my neurons
and then we know that these clattering
abyssion is dendritic a locally targeted
and that we can use to photon gating to
evoke the plateau potential and they
usually the child option to activate
these patterning habitual or using gaba
caging to activate gaba-a receptors in
the same dendritic location this is what
we see that our own branch local
inhibition can affect shut down
dendritic inhibition dendritic plateau
potential but inhibition at the para
somatic location or even off frenched
location has very minimal impact we now
for this talk I don't have time to
further go into the mechanism is
recently published we showed that this
kind of shut down these tender plateau
pleasures and they and then the receptor
dependent so why this matter so this
echoes really nicely with shouting
rounds group to the recent to paper in
this paper through one who put module of
model didn't adjoining linearity in the
cortical neurons and this standard
plateau potential is actually very
similar to what we see in this many
projection neurons they showed that the
inhibition can very nicely get this
non-linearity if with inhibition is
targeting the same 10 drive with higher
activation of inhibition you can open or
close this non-linearity and we think
our mechanism is very similar and this
type of inhibition is me
- bye very likely by different type of
inhibitory inputs a question when you
point it to that left seven traces and
you said that the inhibition was
effectively shutting down the nmda yes
when you shut down an MD a regenerative
event repeat is kind of completely
squashed down to nothing it's not that
it becomes narrower it's that you would
lose this regenerative spike-like event
yes even if you look at X graph right
yeah the amplitudes are being depressed
so it's a different type of effects on
them this this is not typically seen for
example if you put a PV on you would
expect to kill that so apologize for the
now clearing showing in this data so in
this case actually this in the
inhibition is delayed is right over here
so we allow the tentatively linearity
happen first and then kill it with
different timing and then this set of
experiment actually verifies what the
model predicts if we put the inhibition
too early when the dendritic patterns if
you give inhibition too early it does
have nothing to do it cannot kill the
plateau potential you can only kill the
pattern potential when you have a
certain delay or you have a slow
kinetics that's doing probability and
it's the same for the dendritic a
potential directly measured as well yes
so yeah sorry I didn't put in the detail
figure for this one so I in the end I
just want to acknowledge you waited all
the experiments and Takai did all the
computation of simulation and to answer
your question yes it indeed haven't seen
vivo we use two photon living I look at
the dendritic events in vivo in behaving
mice and we can nicely see this
dendritic events when the mice
running on the treadmill and it has a
faster onset in the dendritic location
is a way faster than somatic calcium
response which is not a bad part getting
action potential mediator that's a
fantastic question so this is exactly
what we're working on so we got a web
team ma we who try to trap the function
of related neurons using various methods
for example immediate early gene media
the expression of Korea or chair adopts
and using viral vectors or leeching
loads false Korea our mice we're testing
it right now it's promising but we
didn't finish all the analysis that's
why I didn't show it so that's our
hypothesis actually functionally related
neurons their projection converges on
the same stretch of English right I'm
glad to see the awake stuff at the end
because you know it's good evidence it
away cannibals the spiny cells are not
hyperpolarized the way that you
presented them how does that change the
way we should think about the dreaded
potentials and up and potential yes
so this is why we made a push right you
see all these standard in that
non-linearity so everything is done by
either you know theta class stimulation
in the dendrites and slice or a good man
caging so we really want to see what
these dendritic events mean right so in
this case I show here indeed it happened
and the way we want to get at which we
haven't gone there yet is trying to look
at these dendritic events and using an
unbiased way to segment instant
dendritic activities and correlate with
behavior for example moving speed or our
motion in a very controlled manner and
again this is a large data set we
haven't finished yet but I can tell you
there are way more than genetic
activities even when the animals are not
wing it which is more dramatic than the
somatic calcium signals which often
correlated with different motions one
more question you shine with the main
function of these dendritic
nonlinearities is to drive firing yeah
is there any sign for those synaptic
plasticity oh yes of course that's
that's that's another go to understand
of whether these signals actually have
instructive rows so they can stabilize
their learning that's where the first
slide the go is before we train the
minds to do the food reaching task and
it's actually learn the behavior it's
not in a behavior the performance
actually improves over days so our goal
is to track the same dendrites in vivo
over time and see what the dendritic
activities actually pull a place the
learning instructional earning role we
don't have the data yet but that's the
direction where it going thank you
[Applause]